[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone hopefully the stream has
started without any problems and I hope
I did try to improve my internet a
little bit and we'll see if if it will
be sufficient
currently the the stream health is only
medium but I hope that will improve
hello hello everyone once again let me
just check who was first in the stream
mr. Omega croc 29 followed by
melancholic nugget the great infinite
gaming the logic 800 2 and and so on so
hello everyone its some 15 minutes
before we start start the tournament so
the so called streamer battle now 10
teams going at it and here's our team
there you have it I got Matt or steam
currently there are you can see it on
the right but you can see some of it
since my my camera is there but there
are currently six hundred and thirty six
players in our team but as usual like in
the previous one only the top 20 people
who who scored the most points are are
counted into the the entire score so
these are our top 20 feet in master
Eddie Marsh Rolla freedom master Patrick
o6v Batman freedom mastermind trapper
Papa C alpha zero three six nine eighty
boss 21 then feeding master Mott a
two-to-one then me he'll 2002 user Ava's
here fifty splash Peck last one two
three sharpie night rohan Gupta four
three nine eight poppet Oh a alias alias
on a zero zero one I am too fast for you
Almighty is also here Gordon chess lab
also here thank you guys for joining and
the national master food Torah company
probably probably meaning future
champion and so on bruno poverty which
is also here Bruno and doesn't miss
doesn't miss a stream Thank You Bruno
Superman 89 came in 7 and so on a lot of
players here and currently we are 6th by
I guess by by rating or by hour
up to a nearby the reigning over top 20
players we are currently 6th but doesn't
really mean anything the only thing that
matters is that we we gain as many
points as possible so the tournament
starts in some 12 minutes where we can
play a few games if there are any
challenges before the tournament starts
and then we are off off for the
tournament
all right here's a here's a casual game
against against mr. dodo
and we're just gonna open a different
tab so I I have my this one ready sorry
about that
and we'll see how it goes
all right yeah currently not not working
currently but above who will see
hopefully it improves huh
oops alright there is there it is mr.
mr. doe doe doe alright let's see if it
works
alright we do have time for a game of
two and then we are we are starting with
the tournament and then I'm just gonna
go over your games and try to try to
showcase as many of your games as
possible throughout the tournament and
then we're gonna do some challenges
after that and see what happens
hopefully it will work for those of you
who still haven't decided or maybe don't
know what's going on we're having a
tournament our team against nine other
teams there is a link in the description
below the first thing you will see so
click on it to join the joint join our
battle and you can help out with with
the score and it doesn't seem mr. Dorado
is here so we're gonna abort this and go
not not a rematch obviously go for a
different challenge alright we have mr.
dark oh oh oh wait one-one hopefully
hopefully that will work aside from that
how is the stream quality on your end
here it seems like it's working properly
so let me just let me know if everything
is okay also let me just fix that okay
we have Darko here going for the for the
caro-kann it's clear okay thanks guys
okay the board color is dull well well
that's just the color of the board
there's no lesbo here great some some
thread see here alright yeah I made them
myself are doing or doing okay can't
complain
he might actually be able to win a piece
here although I don't know if he wants
to open up his kings position that much
okay let's grab this guy here yeah makes
sense makes sense but does it really
board good in stoke-on-trent mate you're
doing a great job thanks man
Thank you Thank You Danny Pauline for
for only joking about unsubscribing
means a lot okay he just gave us a piece
so better to get all the all the
blunders out of the way before the
tournament actually starts that's that's
a good plan okay what do we have here
okay let's just go back Bishop age three
okay he's really he's really going at it
let's let's do this everyone put your
rating down Wow why do you say that Ken
ding when the candidates of course if
anyone can still win the candidates is
ding I don't yeah trading Queens here
not and probably not the greatest of
plans since but but then again why not
okay let's just go here huh
okay that's that's that's nice going at
it with the King yeah okay what's going
on here huh okay he's go he's going he's
coming for me with the King this is this
is uh this is next-level chess that
can't be can't be comfortable having the
king over all the way there okay
huh
okay he probably runs away with the King
yeah that's that's all all all great
just gonna grab a pawn here yeah okay he
did that nicely let's trade here there
was probably some sort of a mate there
but couldn't couldn't figure it out
okay and we push the past pawn doesn't
seem doesn't seem like it will be a
problem please change the board color
this is the standard color I don't think
it should be changed okay and there's
the rook well this just wins so let's
just push it not much to do although if
he moves the rook I don't think I'm
gonna okay now he's just gonna capture
that very nice and we start in some five
minutes see okay that's a resign good
game man let's see how our team is doing
ok still sixth nothing much has changed
and what we do have we do have time for
one more game so let's get a get one
more gaming before we start okay we here
we have Mahadi
ah whoo
okay mr. Moody hollow alloy a Louis yeah
that was a brave King that was there was
one one cool King
yes that is that is an excellent a
question eccentric horse who remembers
the final standings of the 1959
candidates tournament now that that is a
question all right mr. Leon oh one a
unit man hello man
are those unicorns yeah probably
okay
seems like alicia's is having some
issues but I don't know they did it say
on Twitter that they are testing out the
new server so they are hoping everything
will work properly that's why they
switched switch to the arena from the
usual time maybe some 8 or 7 p.m. to
2:00 3:00 p.m. Central European Time but
I don't know either they're not here or
yeah seems like offline yeah that's uh
that's shame all right maybe we can try
one more but like a really quick one
okay there's a three plus Oh
all right
holy chess is down Daniel is saying that
Li chess is down let me just check my
check my phone if I do have any such
information that leaches is down it
would be a shame but but I will just
check quickly yeah I don't have any any
insight that it's down ah Lian says that
he was there that that that leaches is
is broken yeah it does seem to be but
we'll find out the tournament starts in
three minutes so so I guess we just wait
it out and see what happens if it
doesn't if it doesn't work out we'll
just have to we'll just have to raise
more money for for leaches servers
there's there's no way around it we're
just gonna have to do it that way and
we'll see we'll see
what's going on okay stream la stream
health seems to be well yeah people
saying Li chess is down that's that's
really a shame
yeah okay but if we just wait for for a
couple of seconds then maybe it will it
will work out that's it that seems seems
to be the reasonable thing to do since
we can't do anything about it now okay
is there a is there a bullet challenge
just for me to test it out any anyone
challenge to a bullet no one challenge
to a bullet okay yeah I thought we just
tested out before before the time runs
out did I even read the comment no the
comments are a bit too fast yeah it does
it does seem like it's happening a way
to wait too much on leeches lately but
it's it's because so many people are now
on leeches instead of like 30 or maybe
20,000 people at the moment there are
maybe 50 or 60,000 especially now with
the situation yeah okay there we have it
there we have it confirmation all right
there we go
see they are having some technical
issues but should be it should be back
and it seems the tournament disappeared
so probably probably they will they will
send a different tournament when when it
commences yeah we just had to pause the
service to find the best move that that
is correct
did I fill the earthquake yes I did feel
the earthquake it will it woke woke me
up but we didn't feel it that that
severely like they did in Zagreb
nenè rucious
yeah leeches just sent me we're probably
going to send another tourney one moment
sorry about this okay so I'm expecting
another link for the tourney which I
will update below so we'll we'll see
we'll see how it goes yeah the server is
down sorry about that
who do I think will win the candidates
well we still have to see how free they
will deal with the candidates tournament
will they will the included job will
they just continue without a job of
there were some very interesting ideas
like maybe maybe the job should play
online a classical game against all of
the contenders and then they just
continue the second part of the
candidates with nine players or there
were some ideas that rebel should just
get a get a wild card for the 2022 can
this tournament although maybe it's just
better to eliminate the wild cards
altogether so we'll see but if it
continues the way it's going so far I
don't know I still think everyone has a
chance like if dink gets two wins in
he's back in the game and it's not
unreasonable to think dink can win two
games so yeah leeches sorry about that
and something is happening although
although we just have to wait it out
they have this is the the leeches org
timeout page where you have this sort of
a sort of an Android now playing chess
with this with this lady who is sitting
on Android I don't know if that's like
like a stock photo or someone actually
made that but it is it is kind of nice
they have robot food there's the flower
so it's a very very creative photo play
chess take a rest never really I never
really thought about this photo since
whenever you see it you just go do
something else
Thanks thanks for the contribution mr.
George Starr L
yes I will be I will be playing chess
with a bunch of you later and after the
tournament ends I will be accepting some
challenges and it seems like it does
seem like my stream is working properly
now so shouldn't be it shouldn't be a
problem still not receiving anything
from leeches yeah we could we could
switch to another platform in the
meantime but my interface is not set up
for four different platforms but I will
I will make such adjustments in the
future so if anything happens to the
platform we are currently using so we
can quickly switch to another one okay
I'm getting I'm getting information that
leaches should be back up but we'll just
have to wait and see all right it's it's
back here and it's back and it seems to
have started or yeah it didn't just
start it they're already playing it it
would seem
all right so do we have a game huh and
all of a sudden it seems that we are
leading with a hundred and twenty four
points this is a this is a super weird
I'm not complaining
definitely not complaining but I can't
seem to to open up a game all right
yeah people say people say it's still
not working although although it is here
so it's working for some people what
happened here okay so here white didn't
move black is victorious okay those are
those are probably the first games that
were that happened okay
I just received information from yon
Almighty it says that he says that he
cannot play but he sees that other
people are able to play so it seems that
it's working for some people but not all
of them yeah who knew that this team
arena would be such a such a problem for
the server's I mean I don't think
there's more people here then there
would be like if we just held a normal
tournament for 5,000 people yeah but
okay it's it's chess you know one of the
best virtues of a chess player is
patience so we'll just be patient and
and see what happens yeah let's let's
definitely restarted okay until I get
some official confirmation from leeches
seems like that's pretty much the only
thing we can do yeah okay but remember
at some point we were leading the
tournament for for some reason probably
most of our players are are just able to
play
we'll see we'll see what leeches what
leeches has to say about this just just
a second
yeah a lot of people saying they lost
the game waiting for the page to load
that's that is unfortunate viviana shard
ESS he just got a win against the 2300
player and which is nice but it's not
not as great if he just won on time hey
thanks man
do I do anything other than playing
chess
during the quarantine well of course
what do you think I just play chess the
entire day you know I also play some
battlegrounds I also play some other
stuff there's there's a lot to do you
know chess isn't the only thing I should
put a direct link to join our team in
the description that's that's a
reasonable idea that's exactly what I'll
do if I can get the link but so far I
can't okay here's a here's the link to
our team let's see if if it's if it
works out then it was the team Nessa
took near the ocean is on the prowl is
at or near okay
Jana mighty has has a theory and why we
are leading the tournament it's because
we're leading because our team has the
most people and then most people seem to
be winning on time that's that's why
we're leading the tournament can I
translate what I said yeah my girlfriend
is asking me have they created a
different link for the tournament but
still nothing
okay well if if nothing you know this
will just be one of the weirder streams
you've ever been on so there there's
also that leaches is dead well said well
said yeah okay we're gonna we should
definitely do some stress testing okay
something just happened although of
course we are not going to continue this
tournament we are of course going to
create create a new one
okay I see I see a lot of people
spamming your messages with copy paste
so I will have to disable some of you if
if you continue doing that since it's
impossible to read anything in the chat
with so many copy-paste s-- yes we just
said it is a deadly tournament alright
have we do we have anything yeah
probably not I don't think I can even
accept challenges are killing me let me
try and accept one okay at least until
the tournament starts I should post more
on my second channel yeah I wish I wish
I could but there's just I haven't
figured out what what should I be doing
I really enjoyed hearthstone at some
point but then it just became a terrible
game and I thought maybe maybe do some
really really old RPGs maybe some that I
enjoyed growing up and maybe maybe
create some sort of a showcasing of them
if any of you might have missed them
it's really it's really good thing to
check out thanks mister mr. salt and
freshwater why do I think chess is
interesting wow that's uh I I think
that's a personal question for for each
and every one why it's just interesting
to me it's interesting because it's just
so it's so endless and you can you can
enjoy it you can enjoy it for every year
the more you uncovered the more you
realize you don't know jack our thanks
for the contribution man he says you
look like David Brent I have no idea who
David Brent is but I do have access to
Google so I will google it
[Music]
oh okay is that supposed to be ricky
gervais yeah okay thanks man I don't see
it but okay yeah still nothing happening
here yeah yeah
Yanni's confirming that that's Ricky to
race a character from a movie okay I've
been told I look a lot like a lot of
different people so I'm gonna take that
into consideration as well from Tyrion
from Game of Thrones - mr. bean - I
don't know there was there was a lot
which oh is that by Ricky Gervais if
you've seen it I don't know I started
watching the what's his new one called
is my girlfriend also playing in the
arena yes yes she is
yes she is in fact if the arena ever
starts
all right 2,000 people at the moment
watching the weirdest stream there ever
was okay yon almighty is informing me
that David Brent is the guy from the
office the English version thank you
thank you young ya young would have been
here I already agreed with him that we
were gonna do a joint commentary on this
wonderful event but as he was traveling
Europe when when Corona strike struck he
has to be in self-isolation so he he
will he will be playing but now he has
time to improve his chess so there the
that's a good thing all right it seems
that still nothing
okay but we are still leading the
tournament so you know there's always
that this is a this is a this is
technically a vlog and I love it thank
you mr. Mishra yes it's always better to
look at the bright side of life
what s be says what are the chances that
I only get black pieces and I win well
if you play well chances are your
chances for that are great okay let me
check if there's any still working on
things
Regis is informing me that they are
working on things that so that's what I
like to hear Thank You mr. mr. Edgar
rust thank you for the contribution
although although I feel it's slightly
undeserved as we aren't really doing
anything here is anybody lagging yes
that's that's a fair question I think
everyone is lagging do the CCO says that
yesterday he felt like a super
Grandmaster because he killed Alireza in
pub G I know if L there is a place pub G
but I know he plays some games young
Gustafson asked him I believe once if he
played some games he said some but it's
not plants vs. zombies like Caruana
so he probably plays something else he
might be playing pop G who knows as
chess players do enjoy games
do I like Bulgaria I've never been but
seems I've heard the very nice things
yes still nothing I need a beer yes I
need a beer as well but III don't have
any beer I thought this was gonna be a
serious stream but now I could
definitely use a beer how's the lockdown
going it will be it would be going
better if I had a beer yeah
do I like football yeah I do I do enjoy
it although I don't watch it like
regularly maybe if maybe if there is it
like the world chess no the world
football championship maybe I will watch
that but not I don't follow what like
clubs are doing or something like that
what is my height my height is a hundred
and ninety-one centimeters I don't know
what that would be in feet for my
American friends but I believe something
like maybe maybe six one six six two I
don't know yeah just hanging around the
tournament stop okay the fish the
tournament officially stopped and we
have clinched first place this is this
is legendary so it's not an actual
tournament but you know we did win first
place in this in this battle of doing
absolutely nothing okay Lee chess is
informing me that they've deleted the
previous tournament going to try to make
another one now okay as soon as I
received the link I will post it in the
description description below yes we
didn't boys congratulations we've done
it we've defeated all of them I was it
was a good day
yes everyone everyone you guys probably
defeated a lot of grandmasters now and
leeches we'll remember that so you can
go on on your profile and you can check
your your best victories and there could
be a grandmaster maybe maybe we defeated
penguin maybe defeated Sergey Chicago
maybe who knows who you defeated how
long will I be streaming well at least
two hours until the tournament ends and
then we'll see maybe maybe an hour more
of accepting challenges until I until I
maybe I get hungry or something like
that other matter stop breaking leeches
yes we do we do break it a lot yeah oh
yeah we have we have a lot of people
saying that they be defeated very strong
players like super brick walls says he
defeated a 2-point 3k rated player very
nice okay see Andrew tank is very the
penguin is very resourceful he's uh he's
playing Tetris now on his stream so I
definitely have to have something in
mind when something like this happens
thank you mister mister noob two point
two point oh thanks for the contribution
what could I what could I play I don't
know don't have anything already here
maybe we could maybe we could watch
watch
Andrew play play Tetris that might be
that might be okay
do I like dota yeah I tried daughter but
I'm more of a league of Legends man as
III started with it and then I just
didn't want to switch what's the purpose
of this stream that is an excellent
question for the moment there is no
purpose to this stream but there will be
as soon as leeches sends a link to the
actual tournaments so we can you know
win another one today to two tournament
wins in a day that would be excellent do
I play play csgo
no I've never actually played that I
stopped playing first-person shooters
like maybe after quake 3 and Unreal
Tournament those were basically the last
ones I played what is what is my rank in
League
oh I haven't played it in a while so I
don't really have a rank at the moment
farthest I got was what's called for kid
qualifiers for platinum but that was
still back in season 3 I think or 4 who
is playing for our team currently I
can't even tell you who is playing for
our team because well whenever I click
on it just nothing happens do I play Age
of Empires no I don't play but I did
play it a long long time ago do i watch
attack on Titan no but I have it I'm
planning to watch it although I heard
that after season 1 it really went
downhill as they hired a different team
so but I will tell you that we are very
close to finishing up our chess manga so
that should be that should be you know
heading your way pretty soon and we're
gonna discuss a bit more about that
after this whole corona
I think dissipates and
it's gonna be it's gonna be pretty
pretty awesome fortnight or FIFA yeah I
don't play
I don't play either but-but-but Pro
Evolution Soccer or is it yeah I think
it's probably so crap I prefer that one
to FIFA definitely okay have you tested
for coronavirus no I haven't I haven't
been tested as I haven't left my
apartment for much prior to to the
lockdown so and I haven't had any
symptoms so I didn't feel the need to be
tested as III don't engage other people
and I'm just in the apartment who is my
favorite chess player of all time well
if you don't know that that's the you
should you should watch more videos
there's this dude who often is in my in
my videos like in every video sometimes
he's above me well most of the times is
that's my favorite player someone said
it nicely here mister site j6 he says
stop crying and donate the leeches yes
that will that will most likely fix
their server problems yeah and if you if
you donate the leeches then you get your
your patron wing and then you are really
awesome and you can show off with your
wing it sits right next to your handle
when you play have I played Peppa Cuenca
no I haven't played him but he of course
is extremely strong player as he is a
grandmaster so I don't think I would I
would do well in that matchup here where
ever thought of becoming a professional
chess commentator your voice is very
smooth no I haven't you have to be good
at chess to be a professional chess
commentator okay Lee chess is working
alright people are starting to write
that leaches is working I still have to
get confirmation from leaches about that
we'll see Napo to win the candidates
what is your thought well he's
definitely on the right path had if he
didn't lose - Maxime in that French
before the before the the adjournment of
the candidates tournament he would have
excellent chance but like I said it's
something that happens to nepo quite
often he starts like a plus three and
then finishes on 50% or he starts really
bad and then improves throughout the
tournament and then he again finishes on
50% so we'll see if he will be able to
hold this lead do I think Alireza
is the next world champion well
definitely he does have potential I
don't know regarding classical chess
because there well it's just it seems
unreal that someone will be able to take
down Magnus and classical chess but he
was a he was very close in both rapid
and blitz so there are other world
championships other than classical chess
we'll had a job of be allowed to compete
in defeat of candidates 2020 Adam I
don't think so
there are some like I said some ideas
about how the job of could join them but
I don't see it happening I really who do
I'm a nun Lowell
I am ain't Karina but after they
reworked her I stopped playing it that
was I didn't feel like starting having
to learn everything from scratch again
should wait for the tournament yeah I
think that'd be that'd be pretty good if
we if we waited for the tournament
favorites pre 1800 player favorite free
1800 player but probably greco and
Philidor
okay I have I have to slow down the
chair a bit so i can read it personal or
nakamura well depending on the time
formal of course we still haven't had
the the ultimate clash of titans across
and versus Nakamura in a one plus zero
so until that happens you know all
questions are still unanswered alright
do I play brawl stars no I tried but
it's it's just not for me I realized
there is skill involved and but there's
no point I don't know like if you play
it indefinitely you will get better but
I I don't think there's there's any
progress to be made in such a game but
you know to each his own Magnus or
Fisher no it's more pure Fisher well if
you there was an interesting interview
with Bobby Fischer I think by Dmitri
Bill it's where he asked
Fischer about Paul Morphy and Fischer
was praising more feel a lot like it was
so incredible and he would do very well
today even if he somehow was resurrected
and you know if someone gave him like
six months to study up on the modern
chess theory and then I believe he asked
him who would win in a game between
Fischer and Murphy that was the question
directed to Fischer and then Fischer was
like
you know he didn't really really have an
answer although although I'm sure he
thought he would win but it is it is an
interesting question what do I think
about Fischer random chess well at first
I didn't really enjoy it
it was III don't enjoy any variants of
chess I prefer just normal chess but
over the over time I really got to enjoy
a few random because especially in top
level play for example that match
between Khurana and Kasparov that was
amazing because you you just remove
preparation okay players get one hour
before the actual game starts I think
it's different from tournament
tournament and then they they just play
the game and I think it was very
exciting okay hmm I have a message from
leaches new tourney incoming one moment
so we are about to start this epic
journey but you know if you if you win
this whole corona business ends when you
get together with your friends at the
bar in the library you can show them
this table score score table and tell
them we destroyed everyone okay Louis
Louis says that it will restart soon
oh yeah I've taken metaphor a walk a
long walk before starting the stream
that's that's what I always do
yeah good luck for the player stay safe
well well said sir well said best chess
player of all time okay that's a
question for you who is the best chess
player of all time write it write it in
the chat let's see if if everyone agrees
do I think dogs have potential to learn
chess yeah maybe to move but not to
understand and the thanks for the
contribution mr. salt salt and just a
salt and fresh water yeah okay we are
very close to the link as soon as I
receive it I'm putting it in the
description below
yeah okay we're getting a lot of a lot
of different who is the greatest chess
player of all time so I'm very glad I'm
glad that it's not just okay Alicia says
no confirmed new tourney yet okay
well just we'll just wing it see what
happens if nothing happens maybe maybe
maybe we have one tomorrow and this will
this will be remembered as the the
weirdest dream on this channel ever feed
a tournament isn't tournament without
Azerbaijan team okay yes Rashida but
which means Medina of Dallas that is
well set sir and thank you thank you mr.
michael butter team a yes go team agate
we want Botvinnik versus mvl
all right let me just slow down the chat
a bit for a second how many real chess
tournaments do I play a year in Croatia
well in classical chess one or two one
or two depending on a lot of things but
mostly want one or two and maybe maybe
two or three blitz tournaments okay I've
received I've received the link for the
new tournament so let me just let me
just shift it over to you guys just a
second
although I didn't receive it from
leaches our idea yeah I did there it is
all right link to the net tournament is
here okay here it comes in the
description below so first thing you
will see you might have to refresh your
page there you have it I've refreshed it
so thank you mr. Eugene Bergman what
does a good matter mean that that is a
secret good sir okay the tournament
started and we are off all right let's
go we have a game we have mock mock
Muto's vs. ms/ms f1 those are the as the
I think Mahmoud already has one point so
so we are playing a mahmoud is on our
team we are playing against the save one
from chess 24 turkey from the Turkish
chess club so we are of course hoping
for a win but and anything can happen
let's see okay they are playing
extremely fast for a three plus all game
so he grabs the rook and he allows the
past month to start marching forward I
think okay Bishop f6 now blocking and
our player is in a lot of trouble now
so we'll see will he will he carry on
playing this or he will and why not
I mean that's why not so now there's not
much to be done here it's it's a resign
although he might try to trade Queens
and then no he's not he he he's gonna
play it like that okay very nice privyet
is easy if you will continue spamming I
will I will have to timeout you for for
for some time alright so we do have a we
don't have a sort of a mm pass going on
at at the at the e8 square we'll see
what happens here
do I speak Russian no I've started
learning but then then just stopped but
I do hope to continue fairly soon yes
Boris Gelfand the man all right this
will be this is this is a good good
example of never giving up so now okay
at least now maybe the Queen can be
activated with 24 check and then Queen
d5 yes he goes for it Red Sea national
nun action yet ah he's gonna he's gonna
try and get a draw here okay
very nice not greedy I like that
the bodies get fonts out yes it is it is
coming at some point and we have a draw
very nice very nice okay we go back we
are currently third
let's check Vee Bateman of Greece versus
area one I think well if we consider
rating it should be should be better for
for our team player but rating means
nothing here
yeah rashidun is medina saga ah one one
day definitely okay we had a we had a
berserk by our V Batman so we'll see how
it goes that's why that's why everything
is happening so fast
for those of you who are still maybe new
to this holy chest thing if you berserk
you lose half of your time but you gain
more points for a win so it's a very
interesting technique to use do I play
poker yeah I used to but not not anymore
at least not actively maybe from from
time to time all right
well our our teammate V Batman is up up
a whole rook so it should be fairly
Swift win here we'll see we'll see what
happens
still a minute on the clock so not not
much to worry about
yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be a very
quick now yes everyone can play this
tournament I've put the link in the
description below so hopefully all of
you will be able to join in as soon as
possible okay
now there's nothing much for for mr.
area villain to do and he will he will
very quickly get checkmated it's a
character's captures probably real gift
okay and that's a mate very nice okay
that was that was great let's see who
else we got here let's see let's see who
is this
okay I accidentally opened it without
opening a separate tab which is
something that happens how did I like a
Game of Thrones Season eight
I didn't that's that's how I liked it if
you don't see the link you should
probably refresh it and then the link
appears that's that's how links work
that's that's a weird thing to say mr.
Penton I'm 30 I'm 31 or 32 I don't know
hmm so good question yeah I'm sorry -
all right what do we have here Koo Kia
with with 1800 against against Rob this
with with two bishops against I said two
bishops but they're actually not two
bishops so here it's just a piece down
but you know anything can happen so
we'll just see that's a check your
Bishop goes off okay that's uh what do I
think about the no castling rule I don't
think it's it's a particularly good idea
since like I said I don't really enjoy
variants of chess and that's especially
that that's one variant I don't enjoy do
I have a job yes yes believe it or not
this is my job I know it's weird all
right he stops the pawn but now what
happens check okay we might we might run
into some sort of a stalemate or
something that'd be you know fighting
until the very last moment okay so he
managed to do something and he will try
to I guess still grab a stalemate
okay and there it is there it is okay
and now we see the the checkmating
technique king and queen against King
how it goes yeah it's the money 20 and
people are still spamming in chat that's
a good point that's that's a really good
point
Eugene dinamarca to join our team there
is a link in the description below that
leads you to the tournament and then you
just click join and then it asks you
which to which team do you want to join
I guess and that's that's just it I
don't know if there will be any
tournaments in Zagreb okay and our
teammate lost that's unfortunate but it
was it was to be expected
okay who else do we have here laka
Baskov against a very strong player
let's see let's see if our teammate can
can do something here yeah although it's
it's not starting so we'll just check
another one V Batman still grabbing
grabbing points I like that what's
happening here okay we have a berserk
from mr. Pablo our friend Pablo is
berserk in a feed a master from from st.
Louis chess club team so all the best
we'll see how it goes mr. Pablo alright
Pablo doing Pablo doing good work I I
kind of suspect Pablo is not actually
rated 1400 as so far this is all digital
good theory our friend our good friend
Pablo is is a mystery man it was seen
but can it be done with with with a
berserk against a feedom master
unlikely we'll see how it goes
when will I reveal the meaning of akkad
matter well might we might do it on
maybe 1 million subscribers milestone if
we ever reach that but hard hard to say
alright what do we have here white is
down upon and he's down on time and he's
getting attacked but he does have
something I guess huh alright yeah let's
let's just hope for the best here
no I'll get matter does not come from a
good meter that's that's not what it
what it what it is yeah okay so far I
don't see any vicious spammers if I if I
check any I will take care of it but or
if there are any of you who who would
enjoy modding the chat just apply I will
make your mod if I recognize your handle
I can just make anyone a mod but yeah
okay there are some that should
definitely be timed out so put user in
timeout okay all right I've put a user
in timeout for five minutes and we'll
see what happens now
yes I've put Z Z in timeout yeah what's
a mod mod is someone who regulates
regulates the chest so there's no
spamming there's no insults there's no
nothing
yes our matter in Esperanto means the
player although I did not know that
until I've read it so it that's not why
I chose the handle 25 okay our good
friend Pablo doing well yeah that's
who did well but in the end it was it
was fede master dr. Tarun who won the
game okay still third who do we have
here Percy des from Serbia against the
hard way done let's see what's happening
here
our good friend Percy des from Serbia
and they're already in the endgame
spending only twenty seconds so what's
what's happening here played against
twenty five hundred hike valve Vardanyan
okay oh that's that's a lot is happening
here okay
he's hanging on that night is nicely
pinned you know you can have to capture
captures with Czech king who has to move
yeah very very unpleasant oh that's just
that's just unpleasant yeah I like he I
like that he doesn't just grab the night
yeah save that bishop he's down a piece
it's gonna be very difficult but he he
is up against a much higher rated player
yes if you already joined the team I
just joined the tournament the link to
the tournament is in the description
below so you can just click and join and
he will continue pushing okay
very very interesting
and that's mate okay
good game sir how are we doing still in
third place which is which is weird that
we are in front of Serge Ibaka and in
Penguins team but it's still early and
they still probably haven't all joined
the tournament but we'll take all the
all the head start we can hey it's Scott
tenorman is dead I remember him from the
streams we played a few games I believe
yeah we played two games I was able to
win both of them but now he's against
the dota is life okay 2,900 2,900 bullet
player and scott tenorman's dad doing
incredibly well against dota his life
check and now yeah you have to avoid
mate
dota is life berserk as you can see and
he will yeah that's not gonna do do oh
so close but but so far yeah captures
and now unfortunately you cannot capture
the point
wow this was this was an epic feat by
mr. scott tenorman's dad but it's a
shame yeah it's a shame
can he check made him in 10 seconds I
believe he can and that's made okay
great great effort mr. scott tenorman's
dad it's a shame it didn't work out but
almost okay we have freedom master Gorky
polenin in our team I didn't even
realize that he was playing in our team
let's see let's see how he's doing
against the freedom mastery Matthew Jie
joining doesn't work I seriously doubt
that since a lot of people joined ah the
joint button is grayed out for you well
if it's grayed out for you that means
you you haven't played at least 15 blitz
games oh that's a shame now if King if
to just screen captures and you lose the
rook ah okay that was a shame so you
have to play at least 15 blitz games
before you can before you can join but
that's that's pretty standard only chess
it it's useful as it prevents the
cheaters from joining ah unfortunately
our good friend Gorky Pauline lost this
one he's done too much material so let's
see who else we got here scott
tenorman's that second percy de we
already checked his game super trapper
okay let's see let's see mr. super
trapper how is he doing
super trapper now again against dota is
life and dota is life again berserk so
hopefully we will be able to score some
points here but we'll see do I know who
is gorky Pauline I think I've checked
once but I can't remember now it says
error if I click the join button yeah I
don't know why that is
Amaya Lord of the Rings fan no not not
in the slightest
I'm actually a huge fan of fantasy and
everything it represents but pretty much
everything except Lord of the Rings yes
I did watch Rick and Morty Eric and more
they are awesome dudes alright how are
we doing here well we are doing we are
doing excellent equal material our pawn
structure a bit messed up but nothing
nothing too serious Bishop e6 yeah and
in the game continues so we'll see
ok trying to fix the pawn structure a
little bit I like it and maybe maybe
activate the knight
that's the way to go
maybe there are maybe too many people
joined okay so we've traded some pawns
still equal material captures captures
and now check is impossible because the
Bishop covers it so the bishop has to
keep on all the rook moves now just now
yeah there was that was in the position
and it seems dota is life is in big
trouble now
he couldn't withstand his berserk okay
hopefully hopefully our good friend mr.
super trapper doesn't yeah okay I
already asked yeah we're gonna have to
put mr. Zeus and timeout so there's that
but yeah I said if any if anyone is
interested in in modding just apply did
I watch Bojack horseman I I think I
watched the first episode but didn't
continue not because I didn't like it
necessarily a there was just other
things to watch at the moment I think
thoughts on the candidates well it's
it's the greatest tournament ever not
not very happy with how things were
handled but you know they have to do
something and well then they have to
live with their decisions okay so now
it's it's it's a pre move war and our
super trapper checkmates dota is live so
great a victory for our team and penguin
penguin steam crossed us but so it's
okay okay who do we have here
International Master PO sauce
h HL bullet okay come on Lee Ches hope
hope hope leeches isn't down once again
wow so many people screaming that's
incredible okay is is leeches down again
is that what's happening
let me check if if I can get some
confirmation on this huh why am I not in
twitch
I don't like twitch I'm more of a more
of a YouTube person I don't know I
actually do have twitch I just don't use
it
okay let's try reloading this
yeah reloading work so why am I not
seeing games huh
yeah it's just not showing them but they
are being played so here are our good
friend HL bullet is playing against
again Matthew Matthew G p4p
who has berserk and we have this fairly
complicated position where he saves his
rook by giving up the exchange but
Matthew doesn't give up the knight so we
continue our Queen trade captures
captures yeah you cannot capture because
you lose a piece here so that was that
was needed if you were to be reborn in a
different country which country would
that be I have no idea so that's a
pretty big question I don't mean maybe
Finland I don't know
okay check-check captures and we we are
up a piece and by we I mean our good
friend HL booth who will save his piece
if rookie want checked and rook f1
blocks but those are those could be some
scary pawns or not rook c1 goes after
the pawns and engage to and I think I
think it's a it's a safe to say this is
a win for those of you who are
continually saying that you are unable
to join the tournament because the joint
button is grayed out you cannot join
because you haven't played at least 15
games which is needed to it's a safety
precaution so we don't get cheaters in
tournaments which we probably will have
who do I think will win the candidates I
don't know
still don't know if it continues the way
it's been played so far anyone can win
anyone i still haven't ruled out ding
have I seen the new doom and you know I
haven't I haven't I'm planning to but I
really really enjoyed the old one and
now we have six points against three
White has a light square Bishop it's
gonna be crazy
should be winning I don't see why it
wouldn't be winning go after the pawns
now block the the King side yes captures
captures capture on h5 with the Bishop
Bishop characters on h5 yeah much better
than then H captures G yeah although
it's an important decision so he should
he should take time although not a lot
of time as he is quite often time twice
yes you cannot capture because of
captures that's that's okay going a bit
low on time here that's not okay he just
gave him so yeah that's why I said
Bishop captures was better this was just
uncalled for characters here
yes capture on c4 why are you wasting so
much time that's that's unreal
and now he has to and now he lost in
time wow that was that incredible such a
position to be lost in time Wow okay
scott tenorman's dad HL bullet V Batman
we'll already seen their games let's
check out myzel I should consider moving
to twitch okay I'll see I'll see what I
can do about that
not about that about the you really need
at least a one mod here okay Mac Lee
Mack Lee if that's your if that's your
opinion you are now a mod ok Mac Lee you
are now the moderator and we'll see how
it goes
yet which is laggy perhaps ok my soul my
soul 10 playing against feed a pro my
hair and well doing doing fairly well ok
he just lost the pawn but it's only one
point he grabs it back and it's oh he
goes for that one ok now you grab that
one and our good friends from here
berserk so we're gonna have to we're
gonna have to win Thank You mr.
alexander lukashenko
update shoot up the [ __ ] off let me
moderate I if I recognize any of the
handles I will let you moderate I can
just let anyone moderate since I don't
know what kind of what kind of a person
you are you know leeches is unreachable
request timed out my birthday is a 16 of
June all right how are we going to win
this that's the question
well on time that's that's one way to go
about it
do I feel Croatia is handling the
current covert outbreak well well
considering how some other unfortunate
countries are doing I would say yes you
I mean you can always do better but and
it's it's the wrong the bishop so
unfortunately we only we only get a draw
here unless unless myzel tries to unless
myzel tries to flag him
yeah he just stalemated him but it's it
was the correct decision trying to flag
with 28 seconds on the clock would be
would just be an overkill okay so we've
dropped the fifth place but it is what
we were expecting
let's see alpha zero mister alpha zero
playing against the chess player one 407
let's see if he can live up to the name
no I've never visited India but I
definitely will yeah pi/3 more often as
people have a lot of questions what will
feed I do with stay more a job of
probably ignore him that's that's my
opinion
do i watch chess talk no no I do not I
don't know who is chess talk I know that
I know they're pretty they have a pretty
big following but I have no idea who
they are
do I think stockfish 11 is stronger than
alpha zero no of course not no one no
one and nothing is stronger than alpha
zero
spot any disgusting engine lighting in a
three mil a three minute game not not
exactly yeah I will at okay now that the
candidates is over in that we only have
the Murphy saga and pretty much nothing
else is going on in the chess world I
probably will be streaming a lot more
and I will start creating maybe even
daily tournaments but you know all in
all in due time
am i a fan of Magnus Carlsen sure who
isn't a fan of Magnus is the internet
better yes my internet is better I think
so
and as I really wanted to start my
podcast like maybe even maybe even a
month ago but now I will not be able to
bring any guests over so even if this
whole situation continues I might I
might have to do it over Skype but I
really wanted to bring guests in over in
person
okay alpha0 doing doing well here that
black king is is okay what if what if
not just captures on d4 we have a check
ok nice nice I have a check on c4 or do
we because all know people are saying
glitches is down again and but the game
continues yeah I thought he'd play that
although I don't see why Bishop captures
wasn't playable
okay Hercules you are you are banned for
that comments or you okay it's back
people say its back so those who had
more time on the clock should be very
happy now
and we have we have a descent game with
equal material and are our good friend
offer zero being a little bit lower on
time so do do you grab the night do not
grab the night what's what's happening
here do I use leeches because it's open
source mmm one of the reasons why yes
not not only because it's open source
but also because it's free its it's the
most stable one not not all the time but
when it is and you don't lose time when
you pre move I hate when you lose time
when you pre move it just takes all the
fun out of removing and it's just smooth
it's just really smooth no ads there's
nothing not to like okay we have a
bullet war here yeah now check pick up
the h7 pawn hopefully and then good
things might happen or not
oh it's getting it's getting very
crowded there okay yep that's that's
yeah he will try to to at least do
something but there is nothing to be
done here it was it was good while it
lasted
okay let me just refresh my streaming
page because that that's also lagging
still have questions no no I don't why
is it called a night instead of a horse
that's that's a good question
okay that's another timeout okay we are
holding it in fifth place let's check
out mr. mind trapper how is he doing
unless unless we will not be checking
out anything nice beer glass where's the
oh yeah that's a beer glass ha ha
that is a beer glass indeed and is
doesn't seem like it's responding let's
try a different player Almighty Oh yon
Almighty winning us a lot of points
that's what I like to see let's let's
see if we can check out his game it
doesn't seem like we're able to check
more games
huh
and we have we have confirmation that
that it's dead again not only not only
the delicious but also my stream seems
seems not to be working properly or is
it I know this is just this is just too
much I don't think we can we can repeat
it no stream is doing well stream is
doing well sure about that yes the
server is dead but my stream is good
that's you know last time this the the
servers were great but my stream was bad
this time my stream is good but that was
bad
yeah a stream is good indeed okay so
maybe it nope still again with this with
this nice photo okay so while we well we
wait maybe the tournament Murray
continues too bad I was very much
looking forward to checking out a Yuans
game okay we we got it back but and it
seems we got the points for a win
because it timed out it's unfortunate
let's see if it if it goes back again
huh yeah
from from 20 people streaming there are
now like three who is my favorite to win
the candidates well before the the
candidates even started my favorite was
a job of but now that our job is not
playing I I don't know I would
definitely want to see an epic versus
Carlson because if we if we had like a
French defense game where Magnus had
white and never had black in a world
championship game whew you know it just
doesn't get better than that yeah we'll
see
keep keep pressing maybe something
happens yes impossible to play like this
hey mickey dramatic oh hello sir I'm
good to have you in the chat okay we're
back we're all mighty lost for some
reason are we back
now almighty has 35 points that's that's
really weird
[Music]
you wanted among how to win well he is
definitely up there
what about Caruana Khurana had his
chance in 2018 and he was he was very
close but if you don't take him out if
you don't take Magnus out in classical
your chances just get a whole lot lower
no I don't spam F in the chat that's
that's wrong yes increasing its cut
which means jumper all right
all night is still still topped with 35
points that's that's very impressive but
impossible to watch and we are that's
shame we just have a game Almighty vs
penguin oh that would be a game to watch
too bad that's that's a shame and
penguin won obviously on time
I will check if I have any messages from
leeches although so far nothing we'll
see
[Music]
now it just froze yeah okay we'll see
we'll see what happens we're gonna wait
for a few more minutes until we receive
something
if not we'll just have to do it some
other time
okay do we have do we have anything
happening drunk server still nothing
okay any other any other questions does
Corona spread through chat I I certainly
hope not
okay
which microphone do I use it's the it's
the blue Yeti and it seems like the
streamer battle just finished so that's
that's a shame
yep not not receiving anything at the
moment
nope I am receiving something we'll just
see what happens there seems to be no
way around it you guys yeah it's it's
official now leeches is confirming that
that the that it's cancelled and for now
I I guess we were gonna continue at some
other time or maybe some other day or
something but yeah where they say very
sorry blah blah blah
yeah there is no reason to think this
will improve so best just to end it but
yeah we're gonna we're gonna take this
opportunity to maybe maybe donate more
money to leeches so they can improve
their servers there's I don't see a way
a way around that so best to do that I
guess India it's really shame yeah
Almighty did not get his game against
the penguin but maybe maybe maybe other
time maybe some other time but it is
this is why why the team battle is so
nice you you get to play against very
strong players like like Andrew tank and
next time when the server doesn't crash
it's gonna be really awesome but yeah we
defeated leeches yes we have a good job
guys well yeah that's that's it for this
stream then since there is no way to
play and no way to enjoy chests we'll
will see you guys when it improves so a
very unfortunate that it happened but as
it did we we have no other no other
choice but to end it so we're continuing
with the Morphy saga today hope you guys
will enjoy that as well we are
continuing the the match between paulsen
and until it starts working so later
guys